ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERONE
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BRIAN BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA. MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA IN
O'DONNELL LISTEN PETRIE-NORRIS
CORK CORK SILVA RAMOS RADIUS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTO SMITH STONE TAKING
BALLOT THERE AS THE APPROVED BY
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
DAYS PRIOR. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YES YOUR CON YOU
MONEY IS HERE. IN THE NAME OF
GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. HOW MANY GUARD. BE
WITH EVERY B. WITH EACH AND
EVERY MEMBER NOW AND THROUGH
THE COMING WEEKS. THOSE WHO
SERVE HERE IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY FEEL PRIVILEGED TO
SERVE. THEY BELIEVE IN SERVING
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE THEY
REALLY SERVE YOU. DIED THEM
WITH YOUR WISDOM IN ALL
CIRCUMSTANCES BE CLOSE TO THEM.
WITH YOUR ABIDING PRESENCE ON
THE GIFT OF PEACE. WHEN THEY
ARE TESTED LET THEM KNOW YOU
YOURSELF WILL RESTORE CONFIRM
STRENGTHEN AND ESTABLISH THEM
AS YOUR VERY OWN. TO YOU BE
DOMINION AND POWER NOW AND
FOREVER I MEAN. THANK YOU ARE
MONIES HERE WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN DR CHOI AS HE LEADS
US IN THE PLEDGE. MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME FOR THE FLASH.
TO ALL FLASH. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. MOVING TO THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY SERVER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY JUNE
TWENTIETH MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS FOR THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
AMPUTATIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. LIVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MISTER CHOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS COOLEY BURKE
HOLDEN AND MAIENSCHEIN TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
SOMEONE MEMBERS BOLAND WHO'D
GALLAGHER AGUIAR-CURRY THE REAL
CRISTINA GARCIA AND MCCARTY TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR STERN TO THE
INACTIVE FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK
GOODNESS.
MEMBERS. TODAY WE
RECOGNIZE THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY SCIENCE FELLOWS THE
SCIENCE FELLOWS ARE IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER MR COOLEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR MR MULLINS
DESK THE INTRODUCTION OF THE
SCIENCE FELLOWS. GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES. A QUIET ON THE
FLOOR PLEASE THANK YOU. COLORS
I'M HONORED TODAY TO RECOGNIZE
THE SCIENCE FELLOWS THAT HAVE
SERVED OUR HOUSE IN THE CURRENT
SESSION. MEMBERS SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY ARE VITAL AS YOU
KNOW TO CALIFORNIA'S DYNAMIC
ECONOMY. IT AFFECTS OUR
LEADERSHIP AND THE NATIONAL
ECONOMY BUT AFFECTS OUR GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP. EVERYONE IS
INTERESTED IN THE BREAKTHROUGH
SCIENCE THAT COMES OUT OF OUR
STATE. AND HOW IT HAS TURNED
INTO PRODUCTIVE. USES FOR HUMAN
SOCIETY. EVERY YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY FELLOWS HAVE
COME TO OUR INSTITUTION TO ADD
THEIR KNOWLEDGE INSIGHTS AND
PERSPECTIVE. TO THE PUBLIC
POLICY THAT WE WORK ON IN THIS
BUILDING. I AM DELIGHTED TO
RECOGNIZE TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY FELLOWS. THE
FIRST FELLOW TO BE RECOGNIZED
AS DOCTOR NICOLE HOME WHO
SERVED WITH THE ASSEMBLY WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE.
DR HOLM OF STUDIED GENETIC
CHANGES IN NEURO DEGENERATIVE
DISEASE AND THE USE OF THE
GENETICS. IN CLINICAL PRACTICE
SHE EARNED HER HD INJURED FROM
UC DAVIS CALLING STARTS HONOR
DR TO CALL HOME. THANK YOU.
COLLEGE DR MARIE CODE NOW SIR
WITH OR SIMPLY A VERBAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
DR NELL STARTED EMERGING
EMERGING CONTAMINANTS IN WATER
AND WASTEWATER AND IDENTIFIED
UNKNOWN CHEMICALS FOUND IN
FRACKING WASTE WATERS. SHARED A
PHD AND A MASTER OF SCIENCE IN
CIVIL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ENGINEERING WHICH REVEALS OF
COURSE A VERY PRACTICAL BENT WE
FOCUS ON THOSE ENGINEERING
FIELDS FROM CORNELL UNIVERSITY.
PLEASE HONOR- WITH WELCOME DR
MERKEL NOW. GOOD. AT THE HEART
WELCOME HERE. COLLEAGUES I'M
HONORED TO PRESENT DOCTOR JANE
PARK WHO SERVE AT THE ASSEMBLY
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
CHAIRED BY MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
HOLDEN RIGHT HERE THANK YOU FOR
FULLER FOR JOINING US. A DOCTOR
PARK STARTED MULTI GENERATIONAL
IMPACTS OF CRUDE OIL EXPOSURE
ON DEVELOPMENT AND NATURAL FISH
POPULATIONS SHARED HER PHD IN
INTEGRATIVE GENETICS AND
GENOMICS FROM UC DAVIS PLEASE
ALL HONOR DR JANE PARK. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR. DR FINALLY I AM
PLEASED TO RESERVE DR VERY
SOLOMON WHO SERVED WITH THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. A
DOCTOR SOLOMON STUDIED THE ROLE
OF INNATE IMMUNE RESPONSE AND
FIGHTING CHRONIC VIRAL
INFECTIONS SUCH AS HIV. SHEARED
HER PHD IN CELLULAR AND
MOLECULAR MEDICINE FROM JOHNS
HOPKINS UNIVERSITY. AS WELCOME
DOCTORS VERY SOLOMON TO THIS
HOUSE. YOU MISTER CLINKING
GRADUATIONS TO ALL THE SCIENCE
FELLOWS IN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THIS BODY.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME THE
SPECIAL GUESTS OF THE SCIENCE
FELLOWS WHO ARE IN THE GALLERY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WITH
US TODAY TO CELEBRATE THE
FELLOWS. THIS CONCLUDES OUR
RECOGNITION OF THE SCIENCE
FELLOWS. AND THE REGULAR ORDER
OF BUSINESS WILL CONTINUE.
MEMBERS. MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTION AND RESOLUTION IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES.
I RISE TODAY RECOGNITION. THE
HEROES BAKER. I RISE TODAY IN
RECOGNITION OF ROBIN LEWIS COAX
THEM ON THE OCCASION OF HER
RETIREMENT. SHE SERVICE BODY
AND THE STATE FOR NEARLY FORTY
YEARS AS A MANAGER.
ADMINISTRATOR POLICY CONSULTANT
NEGOTIATOR AND MENTOR. AS A
GIFTED STUDENT ROBIN FINISHED
HIGH SCHOOL AT AGE FIFTEEN. AND
SECURED AN INTERNSHIP WITH
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN. SHE KNEW
IT EARLY AS THE PUBLIC SERVICE
AND POLITICS WOULD BE HER LIFE.
FROM THERE SHE WORK FOR THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. THE HONORABLE
WILSON RILES. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SHE STARTED HER CAREER
WITH THE ASSEMBLY. DURING HER
TENURE HERE MISS LEWIS
SPOKESMAN HAS HELD A NUMBER OF
KEY POSITIONS WITH THE ASSEMBLY
INCLUDING WORKING AS MY CHIEF
OF STAFF. WILMER A MINUTE
CARTER'S CHIEF OF STAFF. TED
LEMPERT AND CURTIS TUCKER
SENIOR. IN THE FIELD OF POLICY
SHE WORKED AS A CONSULTANT FOR
PERS. AN SS AND THE HEALTH
COMMITTEES IN THE SHEEP CLERK'S
OFFICE AS DIRECTOR OF FLOOR
ANALYSIS. AND FINALLY THE JOB
WHERE SHE PROBABLY TOUCHED THE
MOST LIVES. AND CAREERS ROBIN
WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
ASSEMBLY FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM FOR
EIGHT YEARS. ASSEMBLY FELLOWS
GO ON TO DO GREAT THINGS
INCLUDING SERVING AS MEMBERS OF
THIS ASSEMBLY. WHEN I HIRED
ROBIN AS MY CHIEF OF STAFF I
WAS TOLD THAT SHE KNEW WELL
EVERYONE. AND THAT IS TRUE. FOR
WEEKS ON END MANY OF THE EARLY
VISITORS TO MY OFFICE WERE
STAFF. LOBBYISTS OR FORMER
FELLOWS OR INTERNS WHO KNEW
ROBIN. AS WE RECOGNIZE THERE
TODAY IF WE WERE IN DIFFERENT
TIMES THE GALLERY WILL COULD BE
FILLED MANY TIMES OVER. WITH
THE MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PEOPLE C. AS MENTOR.
NURTURED AND SUPPORTED DURING
HER LONG AND DISTINGUISHED
CAREER. LIKE SO MANY OF THE
STAFF WHO WORK HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ROBIN CONTRIBUTE TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THIS
BODY. AND WE ARE STRONGER FOR.
WHETHER TODAY OR HER FAMILY.
THEY ARE STILL IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
ROBBERS LEWIS COAX THEM AND
WELCOMING HER FAMILY TORTURE
CHAMBER IN THE GALLERY. WE HAVE
HER FATHER JIM LEWIS. HER
HUSBAND PAUL COAX THEM SENIOR
OFFICIALLY KNOWN AS DADDY PAUL.
HER SON PAUL JUNIOR AND HIS
FAMILY. HER SISTER MIRIAM
ROBINSON AND MELANIE LEWIS HER
KNEES. MACKENZIE THE NEW IN
MCKINSEY. UNABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY ARE HER SON BRIAN POLK
SIMILAR SISTER CONSTANCE
MCKNIGHT ROBIN IT'S BEEN A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH YOU ARE
YOU HELP GET ME STARTED HERE
ARE YOUR YOUR CARE AND SUPPORT
AND YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF THIS
BUILDING HELPED ME TO BECOME A
SOLID PERFORMER AS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I OWE A LOT TO YOU I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MENTOR AND
ME. YOUR GUIDANCE AND FOR ALL
THE LIES THAT YOU'VE TOUCHED
FOR THE FOR LATE NEARLY FORTY
YEARS THAT YOU WERE IN THIS
BUILDING THANK YOU SO MUCH
ROBIN LEWIS COACHED. MR
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RECOGNITION. YES THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS- I JUST
ALSO WANTED TO RISE IN HONOR
ROBIN LEWIS COOKSON. WHO IS
JUST AN AMAZING LADY- AND SUCH
A KEY PART OF HIS INSTITUTION-
FOR MANY YEARS HER SERVICE- HAS
MADE THIS BODY BETTER AND ONE
KEY WAY- WAS SERVING AS- THE
CHAIR OF THE FELLOWS PROGRAM.
AND I ACTUALLY WAS A FELLOW
MYSELF- WHEN ROBIN WAS RUNNING
THE PROGRAM AND I CAN TELL YOU-
SHE PUT EVERYTHING INTO THAT
PUT ALL OF OUR HEART AND SOUL
INTO IT AND SHE MADE SURE THAT
EVERY FELLOW WAS HAVING. THE
FULL EXPERIENCE AND I REMEMBER
JUST YOU KNOW ROBIN JUST HAS A
GREAT ENERGY ABOUT HER YEAH
EVERY TIME THAT. YOU TALK WITH
HER. EVERY TIME SHE SEES YOU
SHE IS JUST AS A JOY- AND SO
MANY TIMES THAT WE'VE- TALKED
OVER THE YEARS SINCE I WAS A
FELON OBVIOUSLY NOW BECOMING A
MEMBER- IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT
FAMILY. HEY HOW ARE YOUR KIDS
DOING HOW'S YOUR WIFE DOING-
AND LIKEWISE I FEEL LIKE I'VE I
WATCHED YOUR BOYS. OVER THE
YEARS AND- JUST AMAZING MAN
THAT THEY'VE GROWN UP TO BE
ROBIN THANK YOU SO MUCH AND IS.
TRULY HONORED- TWO OF THE- NO
NHIáU AND SO BEEN PART OF THE
GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THAT
YOU'VE MADE TO THIS BODY AND
THEY'RE GOING ON TO EVEN
GREATER THINGS- BUT I JUST ON
BEHALF ON MY OWN BEHALF I JUST
WANTED TO HONOR YOU AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
THIS INSTITUTION. THANK YOU
MISTER ALLEN. MISTER O'DONNELL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RECOGNITION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I TO RISE TO RECOGNIZE
ROBIN SERVICE TO THE ASSEMBLY-
AND BEYOND SHE TOUCHED A MUCH
LEGISLATION BUT MANY LIVES AS
WELL WHEN I FIRST WALKED INTO
THIS BUILDING- TWENTY PLUS
YEARS AGO WASN'T ASSEMBLY
FELLOW I TOOK A YEAR OFF
TEACHING AND SERVED AS AS
ASSEMBLY FELLOW I REMEMBER YOU
GREETED ME AT THE DOOR AND I
HAD NO IDEA I WHERE I WAS GOING
INTO WALKING RIGHT IN AND
SHOWED ME WHERE TO GO. AND THAT
I GUESS LED ME TO THE TO THE
PATH THAT THE PATH THAT I WAS
ON LED ME TO WHERE I AM TODAY
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
ALWAYS SAID DURING THE
FELLOWSHIP FOR YOU CARED ABOUT
PEOPLE YOU CARED ABOUT THE
FELLOWS- AND YOU YOU REALLY
MADE US FEEL LIKE A FAMILY. HE
DID THINGS THAT MADE US FEEL
LIKE A FAMILY SO- I JUST CAN'T
SAY ENOUGH ABOUT THAT
EXPERIENCE AND HOW YOU MADE
THAT A VERY VALUABLE EXPERIENCE
IN MY LIFE AND FOR THE LIVES OF
MANY OF OUR OTHER SO WITH THAT
I THANK YOU. AND I KNOW YOU CAN
HAVE A GREAT RETIREMENT AND DO
GREAT CONTINUE TO DO GREAT
THINGS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
INTEREST DONALD. MISTER WHO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RECOGNITION. WELL ROBERT IS
JUST A GREAT HONOR TO BE HERE
ON THIS DAY AS YOU RETIRE WE
WERE KIDS TOGETHER IN THIS
BUILDING. AND- SEE YOU SEE SO
MUCH OF THE CHANGE ERRORS FROM
THE DAYS OF WILLIE BROWN
THROUGH TERM LIMITS ALL OF THAT.
AND I WHAT I CAN ATTEST TO A
PRECURSOR ROBIN SHE IS A VERY.
VERY INTENSE IN ONE SENSE FOLKS
ARE GETTING THE JOB DONE. YES
NONETHELESS SORT OF AN AMIABLE
PERSON AGREEABLE PERSON HE HAS
SUCH A POSITIVE ATTITUDE. AND I
THINK WHEN YOU HAVE A BUILDING
FILLED WITH SUCH HIGH TENSION
AND RELATION TO HOUSE
EVERYTHING ELSE. THE ABILITY TO
JUST BE EXTRAORDINARILY
PERSISTENT. AND YET GRACIOUS
AND FRIENDLY IN YOUR
PERSISTENCE AND NOT RUNNING
OVER PEOPLE BUT INCLUDING
PEOPLE. THESE ARE THE SORTS OF
QUALITY USED TO REALLY ALLOW A-
MEMBER OF OUR STAFF. YOU HAVE
AN OUTSIZE INFLUENCE ON THE
INSTITUTION. AND THAT IS
CERTAINLY TRUE OF ROBIN LEWIS
COAX HIM AS I THINK OF YOU IN
YOUR CAREER AND NAY INTERTWINED
WAYS WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
YEARS I'M JUST VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THIS BODY.
TO THE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THAT OF
COURSE IS WHEN I GO MORE
FOCUSED ON AND A PULLED IN THE
WORK OF THIS INSTITUTION SO I
WISH YOU WELL IN ALL YOU DO AND
JUST MAINTAIN YOUR- EQUANIMITY.
IN THE FACE OF ALL THINGS AS
YOU HAVE ALWAYS DONE. THANK YOU.
YEAH. YES SIR. YEAH. YEAH. ONE
IS ON.
THANK YOU VERY BIG-
WOW.
THIS YEAR
- MEMBERS WE ARE GONNA
MOVE BACK TO THE DAILY FILE
WILL GO TO THE SECOND READING
FILE FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE OF CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL LIMIT THREE
SENATE BILL 1-234-074-0860
876-838-4972 A 628-215-2212
262-407-2408 255-260-6060 SEVEN
TO SIXTY EIGHT TO SEVENTY TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT. 983-632-1330
332-336-2401 THREE FORTY NINE
WE. FIFTY FIVE THREE SIXTY FIVE
THREE SIXTY SIX THREE SIXTY
EIGHT THREE SIX NINE THREE
SEVEN TWO THREE ONE NINETY
THREE NINETY FOUR NINETY SIX
FOR THREE FOURTEEN FOR TWENTY
TWO FORTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR
FORTY SIX FORTY THREE POINT
844-965-1545 1-051-253-3530
553-853-9560 SEVEN FIVE
SEVENTY. FIVE EIGHTY NINE FIVE
NINETY EIGHT SIX TWENTY NINE
SIX THIRTY ONE SIX THIRTY SEVEN
SIX FORTY THREE SIX FIFTY SIX
SIXTY SIX SEVENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR SIXTY SIX SEVEN OH TWO
SEVEN THREE SEVEN FIFTEEN SEVEN
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN SEVEN FORTY TWO SEVEN
FORTY NINE SEVEN NINETY SIX
EIGHT HUNDRED IT'LL ONE IT'LL
THREE IT'LL FOUR IT'LL
581-582-5220 EIGHT THREE OH TWO
SEVEN TWENTY TWO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WERE ADOPTED WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
241-619-2720. EIGHT FORTY ONE
FORTY FOUR FIFTY SIXTY TWO
SIXTY THREE SIXTY FIVE SIXTY
NINE THIRTY THREE. EIGHTY
EIGHTY ONE NINETY EIGHT ONE OF
911-022-2220 424-012-4022.
FORTY FOUR TO SIXTY TWO TO
SIXTY THREE TO SIXTY FOUR
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SEVEN TO
NINETY NINE THREE OH THREE
THREE OH SIX THREE TEN THREE
FOURTEEN THREE THIRTY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE THREE THREE FOUR
THREE THREE SEVEN THREE EIGHT
THREE NINE THREE NINETY THREE
NINETY FIVE FOUR SIX FOUR
SIXTEEN FOR TWENTY THREE FOUR
THIRTY THREE FOUR FORTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX FOUR SIX TWO FIVE.
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT FORTY EIGHT FIVE TWENTY
FOUR FIVE THIRTY FOUR FIVE
FIFTY TO FIVE FIFTY NINE FIVE
SIX TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN EIGHT
FIVE EIGHTY SIX FIVE NINETY SIX
SIX OF SIX SIX OF SEVEN SIX OF
961-962-8630. NINE SIX FORTY
SIX SIX FIFTY FOUR SIX SIXTY
FIVE SIX SIXTY SEVEN SIX SEVEN
FOUR SIX EIGHTY TWO SEVEN
TWENTY SIX SEVEN THIRTY ONE
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN SEVEN SIX SEVEN
NINETY SEVEN NINETY ONE EIGHT
OH TWO EIGHT OH SIX IT'LL SAY
I'VE BEEN A- TWENTY. AND
CYNICAL THIRTY SO. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW IT UPSET READING FOR
ITEM SIX SB THREE TWENTY ONE
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS MR
CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS- THE
CLERK WILL READ BEFORE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY ONE WITH A MEMBERS BY
SOME MEMBER BUT YOU MISTER
EUROPEAN I SEVEN MINUTES THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
THESE MOMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING THE NATURE IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THEY PROVIDE
FURTHER DEFINITION TO THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TASKED WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND AT CO AUTHORS AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE IMMENSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER FOR YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED WE WITHHOLDING
ELSE CONCERNED US FOR ROLE CALL
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL SEE
HEARING NO FOR DEBATE
AMENDMENTS THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. THIS IS FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS ON SB
THREE TWENTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERT ABOUT
THIS IS FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT ICE
FORTY SIX KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT IMPACT ON FILE. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO. CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO
FORTY FIVE. THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER CHIU AND OTHERS
AN APPLE INTO EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY IF YOU'RE SURE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB TWO FORTY
FIVE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE TO
ENSURE ALL STUDENTS INCLUDING
TRANS GENDER NON BINARY
STUDENTS CAN ACCESS STUDENT
RECORDS WITH THEIR CORRECT
NAMES ON THEM THE SENATE
AMENDMENT SIMPLY ADD A
REQUIREMENT SO THAT THE
STUDENTS ARE NOT BEING CHARGED
MORE THAN OTHER STUDENTS.
FORGETTING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
DOCUMENTS RE ISSUED TRANSIT ON
BINARY STUDENTS FACE A LOT OF
BARRIERS THE NAME UNDER DIPLOMA
SHOULD NOT BE ANOTHER THING
THEY HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER TO SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS BOTH.
BOTH ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY TO
THIRTY VOTE. WHERE WILL. CLOSE
THE ROOM. ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE IS FORTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED
IN LUNA FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
FIVE EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RESEARCH SHE
AND OTHERS AND I BELIEVE THE
CARE FACILITIES IN THE CURRENT
YEAR TO SEE THEIR UP THE
CORRECT IMMEDIATELY. THIS
AMERICAN IF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
I RISE ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BOYLE HEIGHTS.
TO PRESENT AT AB TWO SEVEN NINE
FOR CONCURRENCE. TO PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
DURING THIS COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. SENIORS LIVING IN
NURSING HOMES. THIS BILL
PROPOSES A TEMPORARY EVICTION
MORATORIUM FOR NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
SENATE AMENDMENTS INCLUDE. IT
INCLUDING- I HAVE ESTABLISHED A
SUNSET DATE FOR THIS MORATORIUM
OF JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. WITH THE AMENDMENTS THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH FACILITIES HAVE REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION THIS IS WAS
RECEIVED OVERWHELMING
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE IN CONCURRENCE. THANK
YOU MISTER MERRETT SITUATE
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS THE
DESIRED OF A- HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES. FIFTY FOUR. YEAH.
OKAY. ALL MEMBERS VOTED ALREADY
VOTED.
FOR BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS
FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY SIX MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY THREE THIRTY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THIRTY TWO BY THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS AND
ACCOLADE IN THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
IN THE COMING YEARS ZERO SIX
SECONDLY. DR PARK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN MY DESK. THANK
YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B. THREE
THIRTY TO AUTHORIZE. AUTHORIZES
TREATED WOOD WASTE BE MANAGED
UNDER ALTERNATIVE MANAGEMENT
STANDARDS. INSTEAD OF MANAGED
AS A HAZARDOUS WASTE. THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ADDED A
SUNSET PROVISION OF JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST CONCURRENCE AND
SENTIMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR PARK SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
GUERRA. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SO WE ARE. PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT.
MEMBERS WILL NOT
TAKE A FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN SEVENTY THREE
COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE SYRIAN AND NATALIE
INDUSTRIES SENTIMENT IS THERE
ANY OPEN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB SEVEN SEVEN
THREE IS BACK ON THE FLOOR FOR
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
REVISED AND RECAST THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS TO ALLOW LOCAL
AUTHORITIES. TO IMPLEMENT A
SLOW STREETS PROGRAM WHICH MAY
INCLUDE CLOSURES TO VEHICULAR
TRAFFIC OR THROUGH VEHICULAR
TRAFFIC OF NEIGHBORHOOD LOCAL
STREETS WITH CONNECTIONS TO
CITY WIDE BICYCLE NETWORK'S.
DESTINATIONS SUCH AS A BUSINESS
DISTRICT THAT ARE WITHIN
WALKING DISTANCE OR GREEN SPACE
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN SEEING NOBODY
WAS TO SPEAK FOR TO BE ON THE
SAME PER CALL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
PURPLE CLOTHES ROLLED TOLIVER I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEMBERS
ARE CONFIRMED IN. TO PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTY
THROUGH. EIGHTY SIX. WE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN THROUGH ONE
EIGHTY NINE MOVING ON TO SENATE
THIRD READING FILE. WE'LL BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER. ONE
NINETY. ACCORDING SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION TO BUY CENTER HUESO
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
IMMIGRATION REFORM A MAJORITY
MEANS MOVING AHEAD OF A JURY
LATER YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT YESTERDAY ARE TWO BY
SENATOR WESSEL WHICH CALLS ON
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ENACT
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM. IN CALIFORNIA ONE IN
TEN WORKERS IS UNDOCUMENTED
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM WOULD NOT ONLY BENEFIT
OUR CENTRAL STAFF BUT THE
ECONOMY AS WELL. DESPITE THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALIFORNIA THE
GREATER UNITED STATES.
IMMIGRANTS CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE A PATHWAY TO
NATURALIZATION WITH CHANGES IN
FEDERAL CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERSHIP WE NOW HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY. TO
ADDRESS ARE CURRENTLY DEFECTIVE
SYSTEM. YES THEY ARE TWO CALLS
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
IMPLEMENT COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORMS THAT ARE
GUIDED BY EMPATHY INCLUSION AND
OPPORTUNITY THREE VALUES THAT
HAVE HELPED CALIFORNIA BECOME
ONE OF THE MOST PROGRESSIVE AND
ECONOMICALLY SUCCESSFUL STATES.
IN THE WORLD I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS FRANCIS SEEING NOBODY WAS
TO SPEAKER TO BE HONEST I AM
PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL AND HALLIBURTON I FIFTY
FOUR NO ZERO. THE BILL IS
PASSED. THE PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY ONE
MOVEMENT TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY TWO SB SIXTY CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL SIXTY BY
SENATOR GLAZER AND OTHERS
CANNOT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CLEARLY OR SEE THEIR
UP CORRECT ME IN THE SUMMER OF
OUR CAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SB SIXTY BY SENATOR
GLAZER WOULD ALLOW CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO IMPOSE A FINE OF UP
TO FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
REPEATED VIOLATIONS OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY. SHORT TERM RENTAL
ORDINANCES SHORT TERM RENTALS
SUCH AS AIRBNB HOMEAWAY AND B.
R. B. O. HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY POPULAR IN RECENT
YEARS THE RENTALS HAVE MANY
BENEFITS BUT WE ALL KNOW THERE
ARE BAD ACTORS WHO MISUSE THE
PLATFORMS TO HOST DANGEROUS
HOUSE PARTIES AND OTHERWISE
VIOLATE. LOCAL ORDINANCES THE
COSBY NINETEEN CAN I MAKE IS
EXASPERATED THE PROBLEM IS
PEOPLE RENT OUT HOMES TO HOST
LARGE GATHERINGS THIS SPREAD
DISEASE IN VIOLATE. OUR LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTOCOLS. IN THE
TOWN- AND I WOULD SAY GLAZERS I
CALLED. ONE OF THESE TRAGEDIES
RESULTED IN FIVE PEOPLE BEING
KILLED IN A MASS SHOOTING.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS URGENTLY NEED
ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO DETER THIS
DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR SB SIXTY
WILL EMPOWER CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO ENFORCE OUR LAWS
AND PROTECT THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
PASSED THE SENATE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
MISBACH HAND. RESTORING
RECOGNIZE. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU LAW ON MISTER SPEAKER AND
THE MEMBERS TODAY I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY WHICH
AUTHORIZES US CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO RAISE THE FINES
THAN THE PENALTIES SO ON SHORT
TERM RENTAL UNITS ALL FOR
VIOLATING LOCAL ORDINANCES EVEN
THOUGH NUMEROUS OF FINANCE- AND
THE PENALTY IS ALREADY EXIST
FOR HIS. EXACT THE VIOLATIONS
SO. ANYONE WHO OWNS AND
OPERATES ON A SHORT TERM RENTAL
UNIT INDEED THE MOST A FOLLOW
ALL STATE AND THE LOCAL LAW SO
IN DOING SO. AND THE CURRENTLY
A CITY OR TONY MAY IMPOSE A
FINE SELF TWO ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF VIOLATING. LOCAL LAW
SHORT TERM RENTAL ORDINANCES
ALTHOUGH NO NEED TO FOR THIS A
BILL YES ALL. ARE BEING CITED.
AS THE- TRAGIC HOLLOW IN PARTY
IN THE CITY OF ALL ORINDA IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN NOTHING
ABOUT THAT THOSE TRAGEDY
ALRIGHT ARE WOULD HAVE A LOT OF
COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED UP
BY. A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
FINE- VERSO STOCK CURRENT LIMIT
OF A ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE.
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT THE WHAT WE
SEE HERE TODAY IS SAW AN
ATTEMPT TO BUY SACRAMENTO
POLITICIANS. USING A CRISIS OF
TO ACHIEVE FOR A POORLY ON
RELATED GOALS. IN THIS CASE ARE
REYES RACING MORE FINE SO AND
THE TAXES SO IN CALIFORNIA SB
SIXTY HARM SO FAMILIES WHO OWN
AND OPERATE THE SMALLER SHORT
TERM RENTAL UNITS. IN MANY
pCASES SO THAT'S THE ONLY
RETIREMENT INCOME BY YEP
BURDENING THEM WITH A
POTENTIALLY A 5100% INCREASE IN
FINES. WE ALREADY ARE. WE
ALWAYS SAW POPE ON THE CELL
FLOOR ABOUT THE SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIANS SO ECONOMICALLY
ESPECIALLY AS WE TRY TO MOVE OR
THROUGH THE MOVE THROUGH IT END
UP BEYOND THEIR SO CALLED BID
UP PRICES SO NOW IN OUR
ABSOLUTELY THE WRONG TIME NOW
IT'S THE ABSOLUTE WRONG TIME TO
RAISE FINANCE SO LIKE THIS ALL
ON OUR SMALLER AND A SHORT TERM
RENTAL OWNERS. SUCH A PRIME-
THAT TAKES PLACE IN RENTAL
HOMES ON THEIR OWN ALSO WILL
HAVE A NO CONTROL WHATSOEVER
LET'S NOT TAKE PLACE THIS WILL
EVENTUALLY RAISE NO CONSUMER
PRICES INSURANCE OUR COSTA FOR
THE RENTERS- SO EVENTUALLY IT
IS A HOLDING. OVER A CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS. SO HAS OF THIS OF PER.
OUR INITIAL COME RENTAL SO AND
THE RAISING THE FINE SO HAS
DONE NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU KNOW
VOCAL ON SB SIXTY. THANK THANK
YOU DR CHOI. SEE NOBODY ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM
IS PARKING YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I WANT
TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FOR HIS
COMMENTS I WOULD KNOW TWO
THINGS IS THAT THE ONLY
INDIVIDUALS BEING FINE TO
RENTING THEIR HOMES UNDER SHORT
TERM RENTALS WOULD BE THOSE WHO
ARE BAD ACTORS THOSE WHO ARE
VIOLATING LOCAL ORDINANCES
CURRENTLY AT ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS I KNOW IN THE CITY OF
ORINDA IT BECOMES THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS SO YOU RENT THE
HOUSE FOR A HOUSE PARTY FOR
MORE. THEY COME IN THERE AT THE
HOUSE FOR PURPOSES THAT LEAD TO
THE KILLING OF FIVE PEOPLE THAT
THE MASS. AND SHOOTING THAT
HAPPENED IN ORINDA HAPPENED ON
A VERY NARROW ROAD UP THE TOP
OF OUR HILLS. WHERE IF THERE
WERE A FIRE IN THERE WITH THIS
MANY PEOPLE IN ATTENDANCE. IT
WOULD HAVE COST MANY MORE LIVES
AND SO THEIR ORDINANCES TO
PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS AND THEY
ARE NOT SUFFICIENT CURRENTLY.
AND WE NEED A BILL LIKE THIS TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THE-
THANK YOU MISTER CAN CARPOOL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THE
DESIRE TO VOTE THIS MEASURE
REQUIRES TWO THIRDS. WELL
CLOSER OWN TALLY THE VOTES
HIGHS FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS EIGHT
ON THE BILL IS FIFTY SEVEN
KNOWS THE ON THE URGENCY THE
BILL IS PASSED. WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM ONE NINETY
THREE WITH THE FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY FOUR CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE JOINT SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION ONE BY CENTER ALLEN
RELATIVE TO STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
SUMMARILY MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS S. J. R.
ONE CALLS ON PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
FORGIVE FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN DEBT
FOR STUDENT BORROWERS ACROSS
THE NATION THE COST OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IS A RISING
INSTANTANEOUSLY STUDENT LOAN
DEBT IN OUR STATE AND ACROSS
THE NATION HAS SKYROCKETED
INCREASING 1100% OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS IN TWENTY TWENTY OVER
FORTY THREE MILLION PEOPLE
FORTY THREE MILLION PEOPLE OWED
MORE THAN A COMBINED ONE POINT
SEVEN TRILLION DOLLARS IN
STUDENT LOAN DEBT. IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION BARS- ONE HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS AN
AVERAGE OF NEARLY FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PERSON
STUDENT LOAN DEBT BURDENS
ECONOMY AND STIFLES ECONOMIC
MOBILITY AMONG CHEN YOUNGER
GENERATIONS THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
STUDENTS WHOSE FAMILIES CANNOT
AFFORD TO PAY FOR THEIR
EDUCATION EXASPERATING
INEQUALITIES ARE MANY LOW
INCOME AND FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS IN CALIFORNIA MUST
URGE HIM TO CANCEL UP TO FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STUDENT
LOAN DEBT SPECTRALLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER
LEAN. SENIOR MEMBERS WISHING TO
DEBATE OR SPEAK ON THIS ITEM
PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE HOPE. THIRTY
WILL CLOSE THE WRONG TALLY THE
VOTES AS FORTY FOUR KNOWS
THIRTEEN THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. YOUR PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS ONE NINETY FIVE
AND ONE NINETY SIX MOVING ONTO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SEVEN SB
FIVE FORTY FOUR CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY FOUR BY
CENTER LAYERED AND OTHERS AN
APPLET IN THE CANNABIS.
SOMMERSTEIN ME OPEN. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR LAYER. I AM
PROUD TO RISE TO PAGE SB FIVE
FORTY FOUR TO THIS HOUSE IS THE
BILL. THAT ASKED THE DEPARTMENT
CANNABIS CONTROL TO PROVIDE
STANDARDIZED. TESTING FOR
CANNABIS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW. WITHOUT THOSE
STANDARDS. EVEN WITHIN A SINGLE
LAB DIFFERENT RESULTS CAN
HAPPEN WE NEED TO ENSURE
CONSISTENCY. IN PRODUCT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR STONE
AND SEEING NO MEMBERS WISH TO
DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
INVALUABLE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO THE BILL IS PASSED. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS ONE NINETY EIGHT AND. ONE
NINETY NINE. DURING THE FILE
ITEM TWO HUNDRED SB SEVEN SEVEN
NINE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY NINE BY
CENTER BECKER AN APPLE INTO
EMPLOYMENT. NUMBER TWO YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
SEVEN NINE THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITY ACT BY SENATOR
BACKER. EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC WORKERS WITH BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT OUR VETERANS THE
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS HAVE
STRUGGLED TO FIND OPPORTUNITIES
TO EARN A LIVING. WE KNOW THAT
ONE OF THE BEST WAYS TO HELP
THEM BOUNCE BACK FROM THE
IMPACT OF COVERT IS TO OFFER
INDIVIDUALS TRAINING AND
EMPLOYMENT SKILLS TOGETHER. THE
FUTURE WORK COMMISSION RECENTLY
RECOMMENDED THAT THE STATE
EXPAND FINANCIAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO TRANSITIONAL WORK
MODELS THIS BILL ADDS
TRANSITIONAL WORK MODELS LIKE
EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL ENTERPRISES.
AND WORKERS COOPS THEY CAN BE
CONSIDERED BY THE LABOR WORK
FORCE DEPLOYMENT BOARDS WHEN
FUNDING EARN AND LEARN
PROGRAMMES. THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THE ROLE OF DC'S AND
WORKER COOPS IN ARE
TRANSITIONING WORKFORCE- IT'S
THE BILL'S RECEIVED SUBSTANTIAL
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN SEEING NO
MEMBERS WISHING TO DEBATE OR
DISCUSS THIS ITEM WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. PURPLE CLOSER
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THE BILL IS
PASSED. SIX PASADENA FILE ITEM
TO- WONDERING IS TO FILE ITEM
TO- TO- SB FIFTY TWO PURPLE
READ SENATE BILL FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
REMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT S. B.
FIFTY TWO ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
DODD. THIS BILL CLARIFIES THE
PROVISIONS OF THE EMERGENCY
SERVICE ACT APPLIED TO G. D.
ENERGIZED ASIAN EVENTS ALSO
KNOWN AS PSP'S SB FIFTY TWO
SUPER CLARIFIES THE TERM
INCLUDES A BIT OF THE INCLUDES
S. PS PS FOR PURPOSES OF
LOCALLY DECLARED EMERGENCY.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY NAPA
COUNTY REGIONAL COUNCIL RURAL
GOVERNMENT COUNTIES THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS ARE KIND OF
CALIFORNIA THERE WAS NO
OPPOSITION. RESPECT FOR THIS
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
RECURRING SCENE NUMEROUS
WISHING TO DISCUSS OR DEBATE
THE BILL COURT WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
YEAH BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN CALIBER I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
THE BILL IS PASSED. TAKE UP
ITEM FILE ITEM TWO OH THREE SB
SEVEN EIGHTY. OR FORTY SENATE
BILL SEVEN EIGHTY BY CYNICAL TV
AN ACCOLADE INTO LOCAL FINANCE
SIMILAR TO YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
PERCENT SB SEVEN EIGHTY A BILL
THAT IMPLEMENTS CHANGES TO BOTH
ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCE
DISTRICT LAW AND COMMUNITY
REVITALIZATION INVESTMENT
AUTHORITY LAW. TO HELP CITIES
AND COUNTIES USE THESE TOOLS TO
FINANCE LOCAL DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS SINCE THE ELIMINATION
OF REDEVELOPMENT AND TWENTY
ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ENACTED SEVERAL TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOLS INCLUDING IF I.
D.'S AND CREUS. UNFORTUNATELY%
THE MINIMUM UPTAKE OF BOTH OF
THESE HAS SHOWN THAT THEY'VE
BEEN DIFFICULT TO OPERATE GIVEN
THE HOUSING CRISIS THIS BILL
MAKES SEVERAL CHANGES TO
EXISTING LAW TO ENABLE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO USE THESE TOOLS
EFFECTIVELY TO STIMULATE
DEVELOPMENT AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SENIOR
MEMBERS WAS TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE THE ITEM THE PURPLE OPEN
ROLL. CALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE IT IS OUR TO VOTE.
WORK WILL CLOSE ROLE TALLY THE
VOTES I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO THE
BILL IS PASSED. NO PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TO- FOR
THREE TWO OH EIGHT. BRING US TO
FILE ITEM TWO OH NINE SB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO PRIMARY. SENATE
BILL FIVE SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG ACCORDING TO
EMPLOYMENT SOMEONE DAVIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS DESPITE
CALIFORNIA'S ROBUST LABOR
PROTECTIONS SOME CALIFORNIA
FLORIDA STILL ENGAGE IN
UNSCRUPULOUS AND UNLAWFUL
PRACTICES THAT PUT WORKERS AT
RISK I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB
FIVE SEVENTY TWO WHICH HELPS
CURB THESE PRACTICES. BY
CREATING GREATER EFFICIENCY IN
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
WORKPLACE ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS
CURRENTLY WHEN THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S FIELD
ENFORCEMENT UNIT. IN SPEECHES A
CITATION THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE MUST
ENGAGE IN ARCHAIC MINISTERIAL
PROCESS TO ENGAGE THE
ASSOCIATED PENALTY WHICH IS
USUALLY A LIEN AGAINST
EMPLOYERS PROPERTY SB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO STREAMLINES THE
PROCESS THE PROCESS FOR
COLLECTING PENALTIES OWNED BY
LAW BREAKING. EMPLOYERS SO THAT
THEY DO NOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE DELAY IN TRANSFER OF THE
PROPERTY OUT OF THEIR NAME
THEREBY SKIRTING THERULES
MEMBERS WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS A
PRO SMALL BUSINESS PRO LABOR
BILL. WE GIVE BUSINESSES WHO
PLAY BY THE RULES THE CHANCE TO
PROSPER WITHOUT UNFAIR RULE
BREAKING COMPETITION AND WE
CREATE GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCIES
WITH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE. I SAY THAT THIS IS A
WIN ANY DAY IN A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS DAVIS.
SENIOR MEMBERS WISH TO DISCUSS.
OR DEBATE THE BILL THE PARK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES I FIFTY SIX I FIFTY
SEVEN KNOWS FIVE THE BILL IS
PASSED. EXCELLENT A FILE ITEM
TO TEN SB SIX TWO SIX OR FORTY.
SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY SIX BY
CENTER DOT AN APPLE INTO WATER
RESOURCES SUMMER FRIEDMAN YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE 2% SB SIX
TWO SIX ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
DODD. SB SIX TWO SIX WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES D. W. R. TO USE
DESIGN BUILD AND CONSTRUCTION
MANAGER GENERAL CONTRACTOR
PROCUREMENT METHODS FOR PROJECT
DELIVERY FOR FACILITIES OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT INCLUDING
THE DELTA CONVEYANCE. D. W. OUR
STATE WATER PROJECT DRIVES OVER
FOUR HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY ANNUALLY
PROVIDING WATER TO TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF FARMLAND. THE
STATE WATER PROJECT A DIFFERENT
ADDITIONALLY DELIVERS EXTENSIVE
HYDROELECTRIC POWER AND FLOOD
PROTECTION. MUCH OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORTS
THE SYSTEM IS OVER SIXTY YEARS
OLD AND ISSUES OF SUBSIDENCE
AND CLIMATE CHANGE HAVE
INCREASED THE CHALLENGES AND
DEMANDS ON MAINTENANCE OF THIS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
AUTHORITY TO UTILIZE HIS
PROCUREMENT METHODS WILL
PROVIDE YOU HAVE YOUR WITH
GREATER FLEXIBILITY AND
EXPERTISE WHEN CONSTRUCTING
CRITICAL WATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND ACCELERATING PROJECT
COMPLETION. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING
NO MEMBERS WISH TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE THE ITEM THE PURPLE
OPEN. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES AS FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS THREE THE BILL IS PASSED.
WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS. TO ELEVEN THREE TO
FOURTEEN. BRING US UP FILE ITEM
TO FIFTEEN SB EIGHT CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND OTHERS AND
I'M CALLING TO HOUSING. SOME OF
OUR DAILY EMAIL OPEN. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL EXTENDS THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CRISIS ACT UNTIL TWENTY
THIRTY. THAT ACT AUTHORIZED
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO GREEN
LIGHT HOUSING PERMITS THAT
ALREADY MEET EXISTING ZONING
DESIGN REVIEW AND OTHER RULES
THE BILL HAS THE SUPPORT OF
HOME BUILDERS AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ADVOCATES. AND HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN VOTES
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
DALY. SEEING NO MEMBERS WISHING
TO DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE ITEM
THE PURPLE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CORP WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE TRUTH HIGHS FIFTY
SEVEN KNOWS ONE THE BILL IS
PASSED. WILL MOVE ON FILE ITEM
TO SIXTEEN SB FOURTEEN FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTY FOUR WITH THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW. CITABLE
FOURTEEN WITH MEMBERS VICE
MEMBER LOW. CARRILLO IN THE
OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SPEAKING I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU FOR BREVITY
ARE SEEING AND HEARING NO
DISCUSSION WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY
NAME THE EYES HAVE IT THE
MEMBERS ARE L. TO PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. WE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS TO
SEVENTEEN THROUGH TO NINETEEN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
SB THREE SIXTY TWO CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY
TWO BY SEVEN NEWMAN AN ACCOLADE
TO HEALING ARTS. SUMMER RUBIO
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY TWO
WHICH PROHIBITS THE APPLICATION
OF SALES QUOTAS. OR PERFORMANCE
BASED METRICS THAT INTERFERE
WITH THE PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT
ARE PHARMACISTS. ARE
NEIGHBORHOODS PHARMACISTS
DISPENSE NEARLY 70% OF ALL
PRESCRIPTIONS UNFORTUNATELY
THEY FACE PROFIT DRIVEN SELL
QUOTAS SUCH AS ENROLLING 40% OF
PATIENTS INTO AUTOMATIC REFILL
PROGRAMS. AND FILLING A MINIMUM
NUMBER OF PRESCRIPTIONS PER
HOUR THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE SAFE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE. THE BILL IS NOT JUST
ABOUT PROTECTING PHARMACIST
IT'S REALLY ABOUT PROTECTING US
FROM HAYES AND MISTAKES. AS
PATIENTS WE DEPEND ON LICENSE
PHARMACIST TO BE OUR LAST LINE
OF DEFENSE AGAINST MEDICAL
ERRORS AND TO ENSURE THAT OUR
HEALING MEDICINES ARE EFFECTIVE
EFFECTIVELY ADMINISTERED.
INCLUDING TO THE ELDERLY AND
DISABLED NEARLY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
HARMED ANNUALLY BY AN-
UNINFORMED OR IMPROPER USE OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. SB THREE
SIXTY TWO WILL ENSURE THAT
PHARMACISTS WILL BE ABLE TO
HONOR THEIR OATH AND MAKE
MEDICAL DECISIONS. BASED ON
PATIENT NEEDS NOT ARBITRARY
CORTEZ SB THREE SIXTY TWO WOULD
BE THE FIRST LAW IN THE NATION
TO OUTLAW SUCH QUOTAS. IT HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND IS SUPPORTED
BY A BROAD COALITION OF GROUPS
INCLUDING U. S. C. W.
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF PHARMACY AND THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO SEEING NO
MEMBERS WISH TO DISCUSS OR
DEBATE THE OTHER MCCORKLE OPEN
THE ROLE. CALL NUMBERS THOUGH
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTES I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO THE BILLS PASSED. NEXT
MOVES TO FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
ONE SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT. CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY CENTER
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS AND
ACCORDING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRKY ME OPEN.
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
BYSENATOR GONZALEZ WILL HELP
PROMOTE THE DEPLOYMENT. OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. CURRENTLY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN CALIFORNIA OF
DIFFERENT FIBER INSTALLATION
REQUIREMENTS WHICH OFTEN CAUSES
A MAJOR DELAY IN BROADBAND
PROJECT APPROVAL AND
DEPLOYMENT. AND I HAVE HEARD
FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE ABOUT THIS
SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT WILL
ADDRESS THIS LACK OF CONTINUITY
BY CREATING A STATEWIDE
STANDARD. FOR MICRO TRENCHING
AS A DEPLOYMENT OPTION FOR
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. SB
THREE SEVEN EIGHT WILL PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR GONZALEZ I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE ARRIVE OF. THANK YOU DR
WORK SCENE NO MEMBERS WAS TO
DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE ITEM
PURPLE OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
FOR WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY ONE
KNOWS ONE THE BILL IS PASSED.
MICHELLE YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RESCIND
THE ACTION WHEREBY WE MOVED
ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN S. B. TWO
EIGHTY FOUR STERN. TO THE
INACTIVE FILE I ASK THAT THE
BILL BE DEEMED READ A SECOND
TIME AND THEN MOVED TO THE
INACTIVE FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER PLEASE REMOVE ITEM
EIGHTY EIGHT SB THREE OH TWO
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CONTRACTIONS
OR SOMETHING THE ORDER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL PASS A
ROUTINE ON FILE ITEMS. TO
TWENTY TO THREE TO TWENTY FOUR
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
FIVE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY ONE BY CENTER
BY CAL SKI AND ACCOLADES
CONSUMER DEBT. A MEMBER
GALLAGHER YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SB FIVE THIRTY
ONE BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI.
WHICH REQUIRES THE DEBT
COLLECTORS WHO HAVE DELINQUENT
DEBT ASSIGNED TO THEM POSSESS
PROOF. THAT THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO COLLECT ON THE
DEBT. THE BILL ALSO GIVES THE
CONSUMER THE RIGHT TO REQUEST
THIS PROOF ALONG WITH OTHER
BASIC INFORMATION ABOUT THE
DEATH. THESE RIGHTS ARE THE
SAME AS THOSE ALREADY FOUND IN
THE FAIR DEBT BUYING PRACTICES
ACT. THEY ARE BASIC AND
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
GALLAGHER SEEING NO MEMBERS WHO
WISH TO DISCUSS OR DEBATE THE
ITEM PURPLE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS WE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS MOVED TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO THE BILL IS PASSED. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS TO TWENTY SIX THROUGH TWO
THIRTY TWO. WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY THREE. WE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
FOUR. BRING US THE FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY FIVE SB THREE TWENTY FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY WITH A MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO SALAS.
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I AM PRESENTING
AMENDMENTS TO SB THREE TWENTY-
FROM SENATOR EGGMAN A BILL THAT
WILL BE- WILL BETTER PROTECT
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC ABUSE
FROM GUN VIOLENCE. THESE%
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY HOW SB THREE
TWENTY WILL WORK WITHIN THE
EXISTING FRAMEWORK OF THE
FIREARM RELINQUISHING PROCESS.
WILL ACT CO AUTHORS AND AT
CHARTERING OUT AMENDMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WOULD.
PASSES THE MEMBERS BY VOICE
VOTE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALTHOUGH THE PERSON NAME YOU
GUYS HAVE AT THE MOMENT
THROUGHOUT THE PRINT BILLS BACK
THE BILL TACK TO PRINT. ALL
DIFFERENT ABOUT COMPILE. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM. THREE TWO THIRTY SIX.
BRING US FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
SEVEN SB FIVE NINETY FOUR.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY FOUR
BUT SOONER LASER AND APPLE
INTELLECTUALS AND CLEARLY YEARS
HERE UP THE QUICK IMMEDIATELY
SO NEVER MIND YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES THE RELEASE OF
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS DATA HAS
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED
LEAVING THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT TO MOVE BACK THE DEADLINE
FOR STATE AND CONGRESSIONAL
REDISTRICTING BY SEVERAL
MONTHS. THE NEW DEADLINE IS NOT
FULLY SETTLED BOVEE SOMETIME
BETWEEN LATE DECEMBER OF THIS
YEAR IN MID JANUARY OF NEXT
YEAR AS A RESULT OF THIS
EXTENSION THE ELECTIONS
CALENDAR NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED.
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR
ACCOMPLISHES THIS BY AMONG
OTHER ADJUSTMENTS SHORTENING
THE PERIOD FOR COLLECTING
SIGNATURES IN LIEU OF PAYING A
FILING FEE AND POTENTIALLY
SHORTENING THE TIME PERIOD FOR
FILING NOMINATION DOCUMENTS. TO
ACCOUNT FOR THIS ABBREVIATED
TIMELINE THE BILL REDUCES THE
NUMBER OF NECESSARY SIGNATURES
IN LIEU GIVES CANDIDATES FOR
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION OR STATE
LEGISLATURE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
ESTABLISH DISTRICT RESIDENCY OF
THE TIME THEY FILE NOMINATION
PAPERS. IN ADDITION SB FIVE
NINETY FOUR MAKES A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE LOCAL
REDISTRICTING PROCESS TO
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
MORE FLEXIBILITY IN TIME TO
DELIBERATE WHILE PRESERVING
TIME FOR ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO
IMPLEMENT THE NEW LINES I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK HER AYE VOTE
ON SB FIVE NINETY FOUR. THANK
YOU MR BERMAN. SEEING NO
MEMBERS WAS TO DISCUSS HER BABY
ITEM PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WILL CLOSE ROLLING CALIBERS I
SIXTY TWO KNOWS ME I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO ON THE BILL I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY THE BILL IS PASSED. WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS.
TO THIRTY EIGHT THREE TO
FOURTEEN. MEMBERS I ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE NOW
MOVING. TO OUR PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. THE FILING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS I PLEASE ASK YOU PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS. AND GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MR MULLIN IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER MR MILLING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS MY FATHER
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER JEAN
MULLIN PASSED AWAY BACK IN
APRIL AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY FOUR
AFTER MULTI YEAR BATTLE WITH
CANCER. A NATIVE OF SAN
FRANCISCO HE WAS A THIRD
GENERATION CALIFORNIAN BORN IN
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN ANY
GRADUATED FOR READ IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO HE WAS HONORED BY
REARED IN TWENTY TEN AS ITS
FIRST ALUMNUS OF THE YEAR
REPRESENTING THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES. AND BY U. S. S. GOAL
OF EDUCATION AS ITS ALUMNUS OF
THE YEAR IN TWENTY ELEVEN HE
TAUGHT SOCIAL STUDIES AND
GOVERNMENT AT SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO HIGH SCHOOL FOR
THIRTY TWO YEARS THE NAME SAN
MATTEO COUNTY TEACHER OF THE
YEAR NINETEEN NINETY ONE. HE
ALSO COACHED BASKETBALL FOR TWO
DECADES AND TAUGHT A SUMMER
PROGRAM UP HERE AT SACRAMENTO
STATE UNIVERSITY FOR MORE THAN
TEN YEARS. HE WAS ACTIVE IN THE
CTA FOR MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS
AND SERVED AS THE LOCAL. CTA
PRESIDENT IN THE DISTRICT. HE
CO AUTHORED SEVERAL BOOKS ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CORRODE
EDUCATIONAL VIDEOS ON A VARIETY
OF SOCIAL SCIENCE TOPICS.
INFREQUENTLY CONTRIBUTED
OPINION PIECES TO THE LOCAL
PRESS. HE WAS ALSO A SIX YEAR
VETERAN OF THE US ARMY
RESERVES. IN THIS FORTY YEAR
POLITICAL CAREER HE WAS A TWO
TERM COUNCILMEMBER TWICE MAYOR
SET SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO. IN A
THREE TERM MEMBER OF THIS
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
WHERE AMONG OTHER ASSIGNMENTS
HE SHARED THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. HE WAS
CALLED THE CAL RIPKEN OF THE
ASSEMBLY. AND HERE'S YOU'LL
REMEMBER AT THAT TIME TO NEVER
MISS A SCHEDULED COMMITTEE
HEARING. OR FLOOR SESSION
DURING HIS ENTIRE SACRAMENTO
TEN YEAR. HE WAS A LEGISLATOR
OF THE YEAR BY OVER A DOZEN
ORGANIZATIONS. WHILE AT THE
CAPITOL. WELL HE WAS WELL KNOWN
AS A TEACHER COACH
DISTINGUISHED PUBLIC SERVANT A
COMMUNITY LEADER. HE HELD A
FASCINATING ARRAY OF JOBS
EARLIER IN HIS CAREER. HE WAS A
CARD DEALER IN A LIFEGUARD AT
CAL NEVA LODGE AT STATE LINE
LAKE TAHOE. A JOKE WRITER FOR
PHYLLIS DILLER. WHEN SHE
APPEARED AT THE CAL THE EVA.
AND A GOLF CADDY FOR JOE
KENNEDY JFK IN OUR CASE FATHER.
HE SPENT TIME AS A TICKET AGENT
WAS SOUTHERN PACIFIC RAILROAD A
VENDOR ACCUSE OUR STADIUM IN A
PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR REVIEWING
FBI FILES INCLUDING A CASE
INVOLVING. THE PLAYBOY
TRADEMARK. HE EVEN DID A STINT
OPENING WILLIE MAYS IS MALE.
AND RESPONDING ON WILLIE'S
BEHALF. HE TREASURED SPENDING
TIME WITH HIS FAMILY AND THAT
ON MANY OCCASIONS- WITH HIS
FRIENDS- THE OCCASIONALLY
ACKNOWLEDGED HIS SARDONIC WIT
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT. THEY
ENJOYED HE ENJOYED HOSTING
ANNUAL GATHERINGS FOR MORE THAN
TWO DECADES OF HIS FISHING
GROUP THE FRIENDS OF JAIL. AS
WELL AS HIS ANNUAL RETIRED
TEACHERS COHORTS. HERE MY MOM
TERRY. WERE MARRIED FOR OVER
FIFTY YEARS CELEBRATED THEIR
GOLDEN ANNIVERSARY IN HAWAII
AND THEY ALWAYS ENJOYED FAMILY
VACATIONS AT THE RUSSIAN RIVER
AND LAKE TAHOE. WITH MYSELF AND
MY SISTER JENNIFER AND OF
COURSE HE CHERISHES TIME. AS
GRANDPA TO HIS FIVE GRAND SAYS
TWO OF WHOM. ARE IN THE CAPITAL
TODAY. OVER THE YEARS HE WAS A
BOARD MEMBER OF MANY COMMUNITY
NONPROFITS TOO NUMEROUS TO
MENTION THERE'S AN EFFORT
UNDERWAY CURRENTLY TO RENAME
OUR SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO
COMMUNITY LEARNING CENTER. A
JOINT PROGRAM OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE CITY. IN MY
FATHER'S HONOR AN APPROPRIATE
MOVE GIVEN HIS LONG HISTORY
ABOUT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
CITY. HE WAS ALSO DEEPLY PROUD
TO SERVE ON THIS FLOOR. AND
PLAY A PART IN THE CIVIC LIFE
OF OUR GREAT STATE HIS
OPERATING SLOGAN DURING THIS
PUBLIC SERVICE WAS FROM THE
CLASSROOM TO THE CAPITAL. AND
WHAT A WONDERFUL JOURNEY WAS I
ASK THAT THIS BELOVED ASSEMBLY
OF HIS ADJOURNED. IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER MONITOR
HONORED TO JOIN HIS MEMORY WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THE SERVICE.
THANK YOU MISTER WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I
RISE TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
SALLY TANNER. FORMER MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
SALLY LEFT US ON AUGUST
TWENTIETH AT THE WELL LIVED AGE
OF NINETY FOUR. SHE WAS ELECTED
TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT AND SERVED UNTIL
NINETEEN NINETY TWO. SALLY
REPRESENTED THE SIXTIETH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHICH THEN
COVERED EL MONTE SUDDEN SAN
GABRIEL THE CITY OF INDUSTRY
AND LOW POINT DAY. AFTER
RETIRING FROM THE LEGISLATURE
SHE MOVED TO THE BUCOLIC HUMBLE
COMMUNITY OF FERNDALE. BORN
SALAS IN SKI IN INDIANA NEAR
CHICAGO. SHE WAS THE YOUNGEST
OF EIGHT CHILDREN. HER MOTHER
WAS A CHEF AT A STEEL MILL AND
HER FATHER WAS A PLUMBER. SHE
ATTENDED PASADENA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN THE ARTS CENTER
SCHOOL OF DESIGN IN LOS
ANGELES. SALLY WAS THE MOTHER
OF TWO SONS TIM AND CHRIS. SO
WE GOT INTO POLITICS MOTIVATED
AS A VOLUNTEER IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTY SIX PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
FOR ADLAI STEVENSON. SHE WOULD
BECOME A MEMBER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY SHE WAS A
MEMBER OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THROUGHOUT HER ENTIRE LIFE AND
STARTED THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS. SHE WAS BEST
KNOWN AS THE AUTHOR
CALIFORNIA'S LEMON LAW A
LANDMARK LAW THAT PROTECTS
PURCHASERS OF NEW AND USED CARS
UNDER WARRANTY AND FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMERS AMONG
THE MOST PROTECTED IN THE
NATION AND A MODEL FOR OTHER
STATES. TO NOTABLY SERVED AS
THE FIRST CHAIR OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE THIS
TALKING MATERIALS COMMITTEE
CREATED DURING HER TENURE WAS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS WITH
ASSEMBLY FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PAT HANSON. SALLY WAS WELL
KNOWN AND RESPECTED FOR WORKING
EFFECTIVELY WITH ALL OF HER
LEGISLATIVE SLATED COLLEAGUES
REGARDLESS OF PARTY. SHE FOUND
JOY AND SUCCESS IN OTHER FIELDS
AS WELL. SHE WAS AN ARTIST AND
AN ACCOMPLISHED ANGLER. EIGHT
YEARS AGO SHE IN HER LONG TIME
PARTNER RETIRED JUDGE PATRICIA
HOSTETTER WERE THE ONLY TWO
FEMALE CANTAT CONTESTANTS IN
THE THIRTY FIRST ANNUAL CHOPPER
STEELHEAD DERBY ON THE SMITH
AND CHETCO RIVER'S. THE ONE
THAT COMPETITION BY HAULING IN
THE LARGEST FISH A THIRTY SIX
AND A HALF INCH STEELHEAD. IT'S
A COMPETITION THAT SALLY
PATRICIA WOULD WIN THREE TIMES.
SHE WAS ALSO A VERY PROUD A
DOCTOR AND MOTHER TOO MANY
RESCUE POPS. SHE WORKED
ENDLESSLY TO SUPPORT WOMEN'S
RIGHTS INTER INTERVIEW FOR THE
CENTER OF OLD FOR ORAL AND
PUBLIC HISTORY HISTORY JUST
LAST YEAR IN NOVEMBER. SHE WAS
ASKED WHAT PRESSING ISSUE STILL
CONCERNED HER AND SHE SAID
QUOTE ACHIEVING EQUAL PAY FOR
EQUAL WORK FOR WOMEN AND QUOTE
AND ADDED. WE'RE JUST NOT THERE
YET. YOU EVER HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY MEET SELL YOU'D
NEVER FORGET HER. AND IF YOU
EVER HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET HER. WE SHOULD STILL NOT
FORGET HE NEVER HAD THE OPTION
WE SHOULD STILL NOT FORGET HER.
SHE WAS A FORCE OF NATURE AN
ARTIST MOTHER ANGLER A POLICY
MAKER A TRAILBLAZER A ROLE
MODEL. A DOG LOVER. AND IN THE
SUPPORTER OF WOMEN'S RIGHTS AND
EQUALITY. I ASKED WE ADJOURN IN
HER MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU MR.
ONE MR MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MISS GONZALEZ IS
DEAF. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
TODAY I LIKE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF THE RANNA RIGHT OUT
OF A HARD- A LONG TIME CAPITOL
STAFFER WHO DIED. IN FLORIDA
ABOUT A YEAR AGO SHE WAS THE
LIFE OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY IN
THE MID NINETIES SHE HAD A
LOCAL RESTAURANT HERE IN TOWN
TO L. TALKEETNA RICO. THE
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
STAFFERS SAW HER BY DAY THEY
WENT TO HER RESTAURANT- IN IN
THE IN THE EVENINGS ON THE
WEEKENDS AND SHE CERTAINLY HAD
A FOOTPRINT ON THE STATE OF
SOME STATE ASSEMBLY. AND TOUCH
THOSE WHO SHE CAME ACROSS IN
HER LIFE SHE WAS BORN IN SOUTH
SAN FRANCISCO SEN MOVED TO
MEXICO WERE SECURE PLEADED HER
GRADE SCHOOL. HELPING HER
MOTHER AND HER SISTERS AND HER
MOTHER REYES RATE PRESIDENT
SISTERS TO RETURN OF THIS TO
THE UNITED STATES NINETEEN
NINETY ONE GRADUATED FROM
EVERGREEN VALLEY COLLEGE AND
LIKE MANY. OTHERS DECIDED TO
COME UP IS THE STATE CAPITAL
AND MAKE HER MARK ON POLITICS I
HAD THE PLEASURE OF MEETING HER
AND WORKING WITH HER IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES SHE WAS
DEDICATED TO SEVERAL ASSEMBLY
SPEAKERS WORKED IN THE ASSEMBLY
SPEAKER'S OFFICE FOCUSING ON
PUBLIC. PUBLIC- OUTREACH. AND
COMMUNICATIONS SHE LATER JOINED
THE ASSEMBLY INTERNATIONAL
OFFICE OF PROTOCOL WHERE SHE
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR SPECIAL
EVENTS WITH DIGNITARIES. FROM
OTHER FROM OVER EIGHTY FIVE
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES. AND
PROVIDED SUPPORT ON SPEAKERS
DELEGATION TRIPS TO MEXICO AND
SPAIN. DURING THAT TIME SHE
ALSO RECORDED AS THE SUCCESSFUL
PRODUCTIVE VISIT BY THE
PRESIDENT OF MEXICO THE
CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION TO HER
CAREER AS I NOTED SHE WAS AN
ENTREPRENEUR AND RESTAURATEUR.
BOTH DOWNTOWN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND IN HER FAMILY'S.
RESTAURANT ALONG FRANKLIN
BOULEVARD. HER RETIREMENT
LETTER BACK TO SAN JOSE. WHERE
SHE WAS WITH HER FAMILY AND
RECENTLY SHE WENT TO FLORIDA
WILL SHE WHERE SHE PASSED AWAY.
LATE IN TWENTY TWENTY- SHE WE
DON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNIST
ELEVATE HER LIFE WITH COVERED
EVERYTHING. THING AROUND BUT
ONE DAY WE WILL HAVE A
CELEBRATION IN HER MEMORY. AND
WITH THAT I ASKED WE DURING HER
MEMORY AND RECOGNIZE OUR
FAMILY. THE JOINING US TODAY
AND IN THE GALLERY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY. AND
WELCOME TO HER FAMILY AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING WITH US TODAY.
SIR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS. WE HAVE LOST A TRULY
AMAZING COUPLE AND CHERISH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS INCLUSIVE
COUNTY. TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF BILL VAN AND HIS
WIFE SUSIE VANN. WHO TRAGICALLY
PASSED AWAY IN A HELICOPTER
ACCIDENT IN COLUSA ON SUNDAY.
AUGUST FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
BILL AND SUSIE WERE BOTH COLUSA
NATIVES BILL THE SON OF A
BARBER IN GARNET VAN AND SUSIE.
THE DAUGHTER OF NANCY AND
ROBERT SAUL YOUR- BILL AND
SUSIE WERE MARRIED ON AUGUST
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
BILL AND HIS BROTHER GARNET
FOUNDED AND OPERATED THE VAN
BROTHERS FARMING BUSINESS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE. WHAT
STARTED AS FORTY ACRES OF WHEAT.
EXPANDED TO A FULLY INTEGRATED
ALMOND WALNUT BUSINESS THAT
SPANS FROM GROWING THE PROCESS
SEEN TO FINISHED PRODUCT
PACKAGING. THEY HAVE GONE INTO
ONE OF THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS
INCLUSIVE COUNTY BUT ALWAYS
WITH AN ETHIC OF SUPPORTING THE
COMMUNITY THAT GAVE THEM THAT
FIRST OPPORTUNITY. BILL LEAVES
A LASTING LEGACY AND COMMUNITY
SPIRIT THE CONTINUES WITH THE
NEXT GENERATION OF FANS. WHO
CONTINUE TO FARMING COLUSA
COUNTY. BILL DEVOTED HIS LIFE
TO FARMING BUT IN HIS FREE TIME
YOU COULD OFTEN BE FOUND
TINKERING IN A SHOP. HE HAD A
BIG PASSION FOR FLYING WHICH HE
DID OFTEN WAS AN ACCOMPLISHED
PILOT. SUZY HELD MULTIPLE ROLES
BUT SHE TOOK THE GREATEST PRIDE
IN TAKING CARE OF HER FAMILY.
AND COMMUNITY. MANY A HOLIDAY
OR SPECIAL EVENT WAS SPENT. IN
THEIR HOME. HOSPITALITY SUZY
WAS THE CENTRAL FIGURE IN
HOSTING THOSE GATHERINGS SHE
LOVED TO TALK ABOUT HER GRAND
CHILDREN. AND SPEND TIME WITH
HER CHERISHED FRIENDS. TOGETHER
BILL INTO THE LOVE TO GO ON
LONG WALKS THEY LOVE STARBUCKS
COFFEE AND JUST BEING IN EACH
OTHER'S COMPANY AND IT WAS VERY
RARE TO SEE THEM- NOT TOGETHER.
AND BILL AND SUSIE WERE BOTH
DEVOTED PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS WHO MADE FAMILY
THE CENTER OF THEIR LIVES. OVER
THE YEARS. THE FAMILY GATHERS
GREW FROM SIX MEMBERS TO
SIXTEEN. AND THEY ARE SURVIVED
BY THEIR CHILDREN AND MANY
GRANDCHILDREN. WHO ARE GRIEVING
NOW MISSING THESE AMAZING
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY IS
GRIEVING MEMBERS ASKED THAT WE
CLOSE IN THE MEMORY OF BILL AND
SUSIE VANN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER MS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM USE
NICOLAS FOR THE BEAUTIFUL WORDS.
I ALSO WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
WILLIAM VANDEN SUZANNE VAN LONG
TIME THE FARMERS AND RESIDENTS
OF COLUSA COUNTY. ALSO IN THE
TROUT TRAGIC ACCIDENT. ALONG
WITH THEIR FRIENDS WE SHOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE A WILLIAMS RESIDENT
BOBBY LEAKING AND ROCKTON
RESIDENT CHARLES THOMPSON
WILSON. YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL
REMINDED HOW BELOVED THEY WERE
AS COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
LEADERSAND FAMILIES AND THEIR
FAMILY AND PARENTS AND HOW MUCH
THEY GAVE THE COMMUNITY. YOU
KNOW AFTER THE DEATH IN THE
TRAGIC ACCIDENT I RECEIVED
NUMEROUS CALLS FROM FARMERS IN
THE AREA THAT WERE JUST
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATED I REALLY
WANTED TO REACH OUT AND ASK HOW
CAN THEY HELP. MILLA'S BROTHER
GARNET FOUNDED NOT FOR THE VAN
BROTHERS FARMING BUSINESS AND
THEY FORMED IN THAT THE COLUSA
COUNTY. BUT THEY ALSO HELP SO
MANY OTHER FARMERS ALONG THE
WAY. THE BUSINESS TOOK PRIDE IN
RUNNING EVERY STEP THE PROCESS
FROM GROWING PRODUCT OF PROPS
TO FINISHED PRODUCT PACKAGING
TO ITS- TRUE FARM TO TABLE
BUSINESS A VALUED PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE.
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW THE BILL WAS-
PASSIONATE FOR FLYING IN THE
LOVE OF HIS FAMILY AND SUSIE
AND HER DEVOTION TO HER
CHILDREN. ESPECIALLY HER
FRIENDS IN A GRAND CHILDREN.
WERE HER PRIDE AND JOY. I'M
FAMILY AND FRIENDS HAVE SAID
THE BILL AND SUSIE WHO ARE
RARELY SEEN APART TAKING THE
LONG WALKS TOGETHER ENJOYING
THEIR TIME TOGETHER. TOGETHER
THEY BUILT A FAMILY OF MANY
CHILDREN GRAND CHILDREN. WHO
WILL CONTINUE TO GROW FROM
THEIRS THEIR EVERLASTING LOVE.
THERE ARE SURVIVED BY SO MANY
OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS BUT BY
THEIR FRIENDS. AND ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT KNEW THEM IN THE IN
THE FARMING INDUSTRY FOR THEIR
KINDNESS AND THEIR GIVING
HEARTS. THEY WILL BE MISSED
DEARLY AND FOR ALL THE FARMERS
THAT HAVE CALLED ME. LET'S ALL
WISH THEM THIS IS A WONDERFUL
JOURNEY TO HEAVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY. MISS CARILLO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO HONOR THE MEMORY OF
LOUISIANA MET THEM AT THE IN IS
A MOTHER OF FOUR GRANDMOTHER OF
SEVEN AND A CHAMPION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND BOYLE HEIGHTS
RESIDENTS WHO LIVE IN THE FIVE
HUNDRED HOMES. OF LOS ANGELES
RAMONA GARDENS KNOWN SIMPLY AS
LESS ANNUALLY AND NOT TO THE
YOUTH GROWING UP IN OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY WHOSE
LIVES SHE TRANSFORMED HER
LEGACY IS ENSHRINED IN THE
COUNTLESS PHOTOS FROM BAPTISMS
BIRTHDAY PARTY SCHEMES
KENYATTA'S GRADUATIONS
WEDDINGS. AND COMMUNITY EVENTS
HER WORK MADE POSSIBLE AND TO
WHICH SHE WAS INVITED AS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF LEGACY LA
LILIANA MARTINEZ ADDRESSED THE
IMPACT OF MULTI GENERATIONAL
GANG VIOLENCE AND LOW
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT IN BOYLE
HEIGHTS ROMONA GARDENS AS WELL
AS THE SURROUNDING
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES. SHE MADE POSITIVE
INTERVENTIONS IN THE LIVES OF
YOUNG PEOPLE BY OFFERING
ALTERNATIVES TO GANG VIOLENCE
AND BUILD THEIR CAPACITY TO
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL BY
QUIPPING THEM WITH THE TOOLS
THEY NEEDED TO TRANSFORM THEIR
LIVES AND COMMUNITY. AS A
PROMOTE THOUGHT AT THE END OF
MY **** IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
RAMONA GARDENS RESIDENTS ACROSS
GENERATIONS BY ORGANIZING
COMMUNITY EVENTS AND PASSING ON
INFORMATION ABOUT VALUABLE
RESOURCES HER EVENTS BECAME SO
PIVOTAL THAT MANY CONSIDER THEM
THE BACKBONE OF THE LANCASTER
AVENUE NEIGHBORHOOD. WITH
PARTNERS LIKE ANY GIRLS
GOVERNMENTAL A COMMUNITY HEALTH
SERVICE PROVIDER BOYLE HEIGHTS
TO PROMOTE US MISSION WAS
THREEFOLD FIRST TO CREATE A
HEALTHIER RAMONA GARDENS SECOND
TO HELP YOUNG KIDS IN THE
COMMUNITY FINISH HIGH SCHOOL
AND GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE. AND
THIRD TO HELP FAMILIES MEET THE
BASIC NEEDS BY CONNECTING THEM
WITH. THEIR LOCAL FOOD BANK AND
WITH ONE ANOTHER. UNANIMOUSLY
THAT COME OUR TO THE HOUSING.
AND ONCE A MONTH HELD A MEETING
THAT THIRTY TO FORTY RESIDENTS
ATTENDED AT ONE POINT. SHE AND
HER FELLOW MORNING GARDENS
RESIDENTS WERE FOCUSED MOSTLY
ON THEIR IMMEDIATE FAMILIES BUT
AFTER THE DEATH. AND PUT OF IN
POLICE CUSTODY OF MODI'S
ACCORDINGLY HOLE FROM RAMONA
GARDENS. SHE IN THE WOMEN OF
HER GENERATION FELT THE NEED TO
ORGANIZE AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE
FOR ALL CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
NOT JUST THEIR OWN. NOTHING OUT
OF MY **** OUT TO ENSURE THAT
THE COMMUNITY OF ARE AMONG THE
GARDENS HAD RESOURCES AND HAD A
VOICE IN TWENTY TWELVE SHE
HELPED. CONDUCT THE RAMONA
GARDENS HEALTH AND HOUSING
SURVEY. A PROJECT BETWEEN THE
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAM
LEGACY LA AND THE LEGALLY
FOUNDATIONS OF LOS ANGELES.
WHAT FINANCING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT. MORE THAN
30% OF RAMONA GARDENS
HOUSEHOLDS PETTERSSON
PARTICIPATED AND THE RESULTS
WERE SUFFERING. THE SURVEY
FOUND THAT ONLY 10% OF RAMONA
GARDENS RESIDENTS EARN MORE
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR ABOUT 51% MAKE LESS. THAN
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
ONLY A QUARTER. OF RESIDENTS
HAD PAID WORK. ILIANA MARTINEZ
KNEW THAT SHE HAD WHAT SHE HAD
TO DO IN ORDER TO FIVE FOR HER
COMMUNITY AND SHE DID. SHE GOT
INFORMATION OUT TO RESIDENTS
ABOUT HEALTHCARE EDUCATION FOOD
JOBS. ALTERNATIVES TO GANG LIFE
AND OTHER RESOURCES SHE
CHAMPION SUPPORT FOR
UNDOCUMENTED AND MIXED STATUS
FAMILIES IN ADDITION TO HELPING
FOUNDING. LEGACY LA AND BEING A
PROMOTE THE ODA AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER SHE SERVED ON THE
HOUSING AUTHORITY RAMONA
GARDENS HOUSING PROJECT.
RESIDENT ADVISORY COUNCIL AND
CHAMPION THE COMMUNITY LED
ACTIVITIES AND APPROACHES TAKEN
BY THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES GANG
REDUCTION AND YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM. AND LIKE THE AWAY LIKE
CHARACTER LIMON WE NEED AND
THAT'S IN THE HEIGHTS. THAT'S
AN AUTOMATIC THING AS WAS THE
MOTHER GODMOTHER MOTHER DINA
AUNTY GRANDMOTHER NANA. WHO
ANYONE NEEDING A WARM MEAL AND
SOMEONE TO SPEAK TO WHILE THEY
ATE IT COULD FIND SHE LITERALLY
TOOK A TENT AND TABLES ONTO THE
STREET WITH TACKLES UNTIL. THE
HER NEIGHBORS WOULD KNOW THE
TRUTH ABOUT THE ADAGE. ONCE
PLENTY THANK YOU ANNA CAUGHT US
ON CONTENT THOUGH. SHE LEAVES
THREE DAUGHTERS ONE SON SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY OF UNWANTED GARDENS
IN BOYLE HEIGHTS. IN DEEP
SORROW. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
AND I ASKED WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY. OF LET DOWN I'M A
FAMOUS. THANK YOU MISS KOREA.
MISS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS A IT'S WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I WRITE THE
MEMORY AGAIN SCIENCES THIRD THE
LEVEL. AT TWENTY YEARS OLD
MIGUEL A WOULD BE JUNE AMARILLO
COLLEGE VERMONT WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH CANCER EARLIER THIS YEAR.
HE WAS MY HOMETOWN BOGARDUS IS
PART OF MY YOUNGEST THERE'S
LEGISLATORS PROGRAM CLASS OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
WHILE ATTENDING MILO MODERN
BUILDINGS HIGH SCHOOL HE WAS
KNOWN AS A SUPERSTAR STUDENT
AND ACTIVELY- IN AND OUT OF
SCHOOL. YOU WOULD FIND THEM
APPLYING FOR COLLEGE ON HIS OWN
UNDER HIS TO LET DURING
MARCHING BAND REHEARSALS. AND
THERE IS BRAVE WORKING NIGHT
SHIFTS. AS AN INTERN ABOVE
óRDENES HAVE A CITY HALL HE
MENTORED YOUNGER STUDENTS AND
DROVE THEM TO AND FROM COLLEGE
PREP WORKSHOPS. AND COLLEGE
EVENTS. AFTER WINNING A FULL
RIGHT TO MIDDLEBURY COLLEGE WHO
WAS EECTED SENATOR DURING
ASSESSMENT A SOPHOMORE YEAR
WHILE IN THE HOSPITAL AND
THEY'RE GOING CHEMOTHERAPY. YOU
ORGANIZE MANY EVENTS TO WELCOME
YOUNGER STUDENTS MAY TIME TO
MEET WITH THEIR PEERS TO
DISCUSS CAMPUS ISSUES AND BUILT
CLOSE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
FACULTY. THIS FIGHT IS ON
CHALLENGES MIGUEL IS COMMITTED
TO HELPING THOSE WHO ARE LESS
FORTUNATE. TO PURSUING A CAREER
IN LAW AND BETTERING HIMSELF AT
EACH OPPORTUNITY. MIGUEL'S
LOSSES EXCEEDING WILLINGNESS TO
LEARN FROM THOSE WHO HELPED HIM
ALONG HIS JOURNEY WAS
REMARKABLE. WE WERE RECENTLY
STRUCK BY MIGUEL SINCE THE JOY
IN THE GRATITUDE HE HAD
ENORMOUS RESPONSIBILITY ON HIS
SHOULDERS AND SCHOOL I WORK AT
HOME BUT HE ALWAYS I DID IT.
WITH A SMILE AND ALWAYS
FIGHTING TO MOVE FORWARD HE'S A
GIFT OF POSITIVITY HUMOR
EAGERNESS TO LEARN HIS
GENEROSITY ENTHUSIASM FOR LIFE
IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL
REPLICATE DALY. WE HOPE IS NOT
A PEACE AND A BETTER PLACE.
MIGUEL I WAS WILL BE COLOR PART
OF THE FIFTIETH DISTRICT AND HE
WAS ALWAYS OUT THERE. GIVING
BACK AND HAVE PLANS WHEN THEY
WERE FIRST EMILY- AND SO I HOPE
WE HONOR HIS MEMORY THEY HERE
AND THAT WE JOINING HIS FAMILY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
GARCIA MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAME SUGGESTS THE PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL. MEMBERS PLEASE KEEP
YOUR SEATS WE HAVEN'T WANTED TO
TIONAL INTRODUCTION. I REQUEST
RETURN IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT IS
INDEED A PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO
WELCOME TO THIS HOUSE A FORMER
MEMBER. OF THE ASSEMBLY. ALSO A
FORMER MEMBER OF THE SENATE.
AND FORMER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR. HE'S A GOOD FRIEND.
AND A TRAILBLAZER IN THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT
PLEASE WELCOME THE HONORABLE
JACK SCOTT. WELCOME BACK MISTER
SCOTT MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
THE FIRST ASPEN IS THAT. MR ALI
HAS GRACIOUSLY LEFT PEACHES IN
THE LOUNGE FOR ALL MEMBERS
PLEASE PICK UP SOME PAGES AND
LEAVE. ME A FEW. THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER
FIRST FLOOR SESSION AT TEN AM
THURSDAY SEPTEMBER SECOND FLOOR
SESSION AT TEN AM FRIDAY
SEPTEMBER THIRD WITH A FLOOR
SESSION AT NINE AM. ALL OTHER
ITEMS READING WILL BE PASSED IN
ROUTINE DAHLE MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
THIS RESOLUTION MISS WALDRON
SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED. UNTIL WEDNESDAY
SEPTEMBER FIRST AT TEN AM.
STEVEN CHOI WILL CHANGE UP FOR
A NUMBER OF TOTAL FIVE SP FIVE
THIRTY ONE. YES TO NOT THE
MORNING. BOTH CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY ONE I TO NOT VOTING.
HELLO SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT NO
TO I'D. BURKE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT NO T<c.cyan>.</c>
YEAH.
ALL. YEAH. YEAH.
OR OR ALL.
YEAH I TOLD THE. OUR. YEAH
RIGHT.